Before, we had negative 2 is less than 2x is less than 10. To get x by itself,
then, we just need to divide this quantity by 2. Since we want this to stay in
the same relationship to these other two quantities as it is right now. We need
to do the same thing to those quantities as well and we end with negative 1 is
less than x is less than 5. This, of course, translates into the interval
negative 1, 5. And, we can also plot it on our number line. To check, let's pick
any random value in this region. Let's say, maybe a 0, since that's readily
available. Let's see. The absolute value of 2 times 0 minus 4 is equal to 0
minus 4. The absolute value of negative 4 is just 4 and 4 is less than 6. So,
that value works.